一你把自己定义成被欺负的角色了之后，
你就怎么想就想不通，
一旦我反过来想，
是他们嘴巴上占了点便宜，
话语上占了点便宜，
但是老娘得到了实实在在的好处，
不管怎么说，
房子老娘住上了，
孩子健健康康的，
有人帮我带，
我还能倒出来，
婆婆还能出去挣钱去，
我有什么好内耗的，
我现在好像不会跟我婆家人所相处的那种感觉，
从经济上他们给了我们很多帮助，
我们现在在一线城市的房子首付是他们付的，
我老大那个时候因为我公婆都还在赚钱，
是我爸妈来免费给我贷了3年半，
现在老二因为我公婆就是生意也没做了，
他们来给我带，
现在老二是2岁多，
但是我跟我老公结婚10年之间就发生了一些事情，
压了很多矛盾，
我老公他们家是两个孩子，
有一个姐姐带一着他们，
然后刚开始我嫁过去的时候，
其实他们家条件也没有多好，
又很一般的家庭，
因为他们当时在做生意，
我嫁过去之后，
公公那几年就好像集中爆发了一样，
她当时就给我们在一线城市买房付首付了，
当时是叫我们打了个欠条，
我也是欣然同意了，
因为他当时说的是他以后养老没有着落，
让我们规定一个利息钱给他嘛，
但是这些年我跟我老公可能也没有发展的很好，
这个钱也没有还过的，
有一次我跟他姐姐就是很随意的聊。
昨天就说村里有一个老人没有被赡养，
没有被好好对待什么的，
我当时就相当于给我大姑子递一个投名状一样，
我就说哎呀，
姐姐你放心啊，
我说爸妈把钱给我们了，
给我们买房了，
我说我们以后肯定会好好对他的。
然后过了几个月之后，
我大姑子闹离婚，
我公公在我们去他的那个城市看他们，
我姑公突然向我发难，
问我说我为什么要在我大姑子面前说什么钱是我们的，
房子是我们的，
他们是我们的，
什么都是我们的，
意思就是叫我大姑子不要想这些东西，
我当时都完全蒙圈了，
我感觉一个人怎么可以就是在背后说话，
就是变成这个样子，
我当时为这个事情就很伤心很伤心，
哭了好几天那种，
我跟他姐就相当于不联系了，
我把他微信也删掉了，
拖黑了，
什么都不联系了。
前两年我生了老二之后，
他姐姐没有来看望我们，
然后第二年他妈过生日，
他跑来了，
他跑来的时候他又干了一件很恶心的事，
她给我老公买一张迪士尼的票，
给我儿子买张迪士尼的票，
带着她女儿去玩，
她问都不问我一句，
过年回家，
她因为离婚了，
我公婆就觉得她一个人过年很孤单啊，
怎么给他打个电话，
我说你回来过年啊什么的，
他说他想怎么开心怎么来，
他不回来怎么样的，
然后他大年儿初二回来之后，
他看到我，
他在门口跟人家聊天，
屁股都不挪一下，
我就感觉他现在就很针对意味的那样去对待我。
我我公婆她就觉得好像是我搞得他们家就是她姐跟她弟弟关系也不好了，
这啊那的就感觉所有的矛盾，
好像我就成了一个背锅侠一样的感觉，
我婆婆现在在给我带孩子嘛，
我就感觉我公婆这几年就老是挑我毛病，
跟我娘家人一起吃饭的时候就明里暗理说我不好，
说我老公太老实了，
说我感觉就是很强势，
不懂事，
这那的就是感觉两家搞得也不开心，
就是所有人都不开心，
我自己也觉得很委屈，
我嫁给他们家之后，
这个房子是买了，
付了首付，
房贷我再还的，
我结婚十年，
我除了生老大休息了几个月，
生老二，
我休息了50多天，
我就去上班了，
我觉得我没有吃过一口闲饭，
我所有挣的钱都花在这个家庭里了，
我就觉得我真的也很委屈，
那你想问我的问题是啥呀？
但是我不知道我怎么自洽，
因为我现在老二是我婆婆在帮我带嘛，
我还要面对他们，
就是我看着他们，
我知道他们对我过好，
比如说我嫁过来10年了，
他们从来没有给我过我一个生日，
甚至连一句生日快乐都不愿意说的那种，
就是他们会给他女儿转红包，
祝他生日快乐，
他会发朋友圈的那种，
会给他以前那个女婿没离婚的时候会发的感觉我也没有收到他们什么优待，
我拿着这个钱，
我也打了欠条，
说白了，
我。
跟我老公离婚的话，
我是一分钱都拿不着的，
就是他们凭什么这么对我，
对你和你的大姑子之间有这样的矛盾，
我听下来的话，
某种程度上是你的大姑子她心里不平衡，
所以他故意挑起的矛盾。
他的心理不平衡在于说我也是爹妈的孩子，
凭什么爹妈的资源都倾向给了弟弟，
凭什么呢？
所以他就看不顺眼，
他就得挑矛盾。
其实你要看到这个关系的底层，
当你看到这个关系的底层的时候，
你有什么好委屈的？
他之所以挑这个矛盾，
跟你怎么对他没有关系，
跟利益有关系，
你有什么好委屈的？
那他爸妈难道不知道这个底层逻辑吗？
他弟弟难道不知道吗？
他们来欺负我的时候，
就理直气壮的，
就所有人都不讲这个底层的利益逻辑了，
我不痛快了，
他们全家人就开心了，
就好像我成了那个背锅了，
诶，
你不好，
所以我们对你不好，
他们就是好像，
诶我们给儿子了，
但是我们给的不甘心，
但是我们要欺负欺负你，
我们所有人就甘心了，
那种感觉。
咱俩现在拧成一股绳来考虑问题，
来想问题，
第一，
我俩孩子对不对？
第二，
他不管怎么说的话，
公公婆婆是没有托我的后腿的，
在经济上是给了我帮衬的，
对不对？
第三，
我又不靠着大姑子吃，
我又不靠着大姑子喝，
我又不给大姑子打工，
我跟大姑子关系好不好，
影响我吗，
影响吗？
你内耗什么呢？
第三，
你老说什么？
他们欺负你啊什么的，
一旦你把自己定义成被欺负的角色了之后，
你就怎么想都想不通。
一旦我反过来想，
是他们嘴巴上占了点便宜，
话语上占了点便宜，
但是老娘得到了实实在在的好处，
不管怎么说，
房子老娘住上了，
孩子健健康康的，
有人帮我带，
我还能倒出来功夫，
还能出去挣钱去，
我有什么好内耗的？
我让你们占嘴上的便宜我可以啊，
但我要占实际上的利益，
我要占际上的优惠，
我实际上的利益和优惠我都占着了呀，
孩子有人帮我带呀，
房子我住着呀，
我还不用搭理我大姑子，
不用，
表面上我都不用搭理他呀，
这多好啊，
这日子难道不好过吗？
我本来也想面是过得去，
不用说不用了，
系不需要啊，
反正谁也不耽误我挣钱，
谁也挡不住我挣钱，
我需要讨好谁呀，
不要老把自己定义为谁今天欺负我了这个角色，
你一定把我自己定义为说谁能耽误我挣钱吗？
谁能挡着我过好日子吗？
房子我自己住着呢，
孩子有人帮我带着吗？
你得这么想问题啊，
我其实也不用搭理他，
对不对，
对啊，
他又不给你发工资，
你搭理他干什么？
我有时候觉得还不好意思，
比如说过年他不回来，
我还打个电话叫他回来，
就是见了面我还哎，
姐，
你来了怎么样？
我就感觉我叫完了之后我就很那好，
我他妈凭什么对他这么好的那种感觉，
他还给我冷着个脸，
要有就是你刚刚说话这种气质啊，
以后我就这样啊，
好，
嗯，
拜拜啊，
反正我跟你说。
真的就是绝情的女人，
先享受这个世界，
就不在乎别人怎么看我，
不在乎别人怎么议论的女人，
先享受这个世界，
经常有一点儿心眼子了，
然后不内耗的女人真的可爽了，
谁骂我说哎呀，
她挣了点钱啦，
就是现在看不起我们了，
我不在乎你骂我呀，
随便骂呀，
他现在又怎么怎么样了啊，
嗯，
都不跟我们一起吃饭了，
对呀，
我不想跟你吃饭呀，
有什么大不了，
只要不耽误你挣钱的人，
事少往心里搁。
记得点赞关注哦。